>> Jon: WELCOME TO "THE DAILY
SHOW".
MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
GOOD SHOW TONIGHT. TONIGHT'S
GUEST THE GREATEST, THE GREATEST
RELIEF PITCHER IN BASEBALL
HISTORY MARIANO RIVERA IS
GOING TO BE JOINING US ON THE
PROGRAM LATER ON TONIGHT.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
BUT --
[LAUGHTER]
I SAID THE BUT REALLY LOUD,
DIDN'T I?
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT, SCARED
SOME PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE NEWS.
BECAUSE LATE LAST WEEK IT ALL
WENT DOWN.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE
DEFENSE OVER A NEW SMOKING GUN
BENGHAZI E-MAIL.
>> SOME ARE CALLING A SMOKING
GUN.
>> THE SMOKING GUN.
>> Jon: SMOKING GUN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S ONE OF WORST KINDS OF GUNS.
[LAUGHTER]
A GUN THAT SMOKES.
ITS A TERRIBLE INFLUENCE.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL THE OTHER GUNS THAT JUST
HAVING A GOOD TIME.
THEY ARE NOT SMOKING, NOT
DRINKING AND THEN THAT GUN WALKS
IN.
COME ON, ALL THE COOL GUNS ARE
DOING IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW WE WENT INTO IRAQ BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T WANT THE SMOKING GUN TO
BE IN THE FORM OF A
MUSHROOM CLOUD. WHAT WAS
THIS GUN SMOKING?
>> THE CONSERVATIVE WATCH DOG
GROUP JUDICIAL WATCH OBTAINED
INTERNAL WHITE HOUSE E-MAILS
THAT IT CLAIMS REVEAL MORE ABOUT
THE EFFORT TO GET THEN U.N.
AMBASSADOR SUSAN RICE TO ASSERT
ON THE SUNDAY MORNING TALK SHOWS
THAT THE ATTACK ON THE
U.S. CONSULATE WAS THE RESULT OF
A DEMONSTRATION OVER AN
INTERNET VIDEO AND NOT A FAILURE
OF ADMINISTRATION POLICY.
>> Jon: HUH.
MAN, THAT IS DIFFERENT. THE
WHITE HOUSE HAD SAID THEY HAD
VERY LITTLE TO DO WITH CHANGING
THE TALKING POINTS. WELL, NOW
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS BEN RHODES A
WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL
SECURITY AND COMMUNICATIONS AIDE
DID ADD TO THE TALKING POINTS,
EMPHASIZING THAT THE PROTESTS
SURROUNDING THE BENGHAZI
VIOLENCE WERE NOT COORDINATED BY
TERRORISTS BUT WERE INSTEAD
SOMEHOW RELATED TO A PROVOCATIVE
ANTI-MUSLIM VIDEO THAT HAD
CAUSED DEMONSTRATIONS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES. BY THE WAY,
THAT VIDEO, SNOW DOGS.
IT REALLY IS A TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE VIDEO.
[LAUGHTER]
WELL, I WILL SAY THIS, FROM THAT
E-MAIL IT SOUNDS LIKE THE WHITE
HOUSE -- WELL DONE.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD POLITICS AND
ELECTIONS ON THEIR MIND WHEN
THEY SENT SUSAN RICE TO THE
SUNDAY SHOWS.
IT'S DEPLORABLE.
NOT SURE WHAT IT MEANS IN TERMS
OF FIXING THE INITIAL PROBLEMS
OF INADEQUATE COMMUNICATION AND
PROTECTION THAT CAUSED THE
TRAGEDY BUT OKAY. GOOD FIND.
MOVING ON.
>> WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE OVER
THOSE FOUR DEAD AMERICANS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: WAIT, WHAT NOW?
>> WE NOW KNOW THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE HAD A CONSPIRACY WHERE
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO WAS CHANGE THE
STORY.
>> WILL THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
EVEN PAY ATTENTION?
>> THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
GIVING PRESIDENT OBAMA A PASS ON
BENGHAZI.
WHERE WAS THAT OUTRAGE?
THE PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE
HOUSE CREATED A POLITICAL
AGENDA.
>> WHERE IS THE MEDIA OUTRAGE?
>> THEY KNEW IT WAS A TERRORIST
ATTACK FROM THE GET GO.
>> NOBODY SEEMS TO CARE.
>> FOX NEWS IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
STAYED ON THE STORY AND HAS NOT
LET GO OF IT.
>> WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE THERE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: OKAY.
I THINK I SEE THE PROBLEM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU THINK PEOPLE'S FAILURE TO
MATCH YOUR LEVEL OF OUTRAGE IS
BASED ON IGNORANCE THAT AFTER
NEARLY 100 NETWORK NEWS STORIES,
HUNDREDS OF CABLE NEWS STORIES
ABOUT BENGHAZI 13 CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS, 50 FURTHER
CONGRESSIONAL BRIEFINGS AND
25,000 PAGES OF OFFICIAL
FINDINGS CONCERNING WHAT
HAPPENED IN BENGHAZI THAT IF WE
ALL ONLY KNEW ABOUT IT --
[LAUGHTER]
-- WE WOULD CARE.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE VERY FEW
THINGS WE'VE HEARD MORE ABOUT IN
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF.
THE ONLY THING WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
IN THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF.
THE ONLY THING WE'VE
HEARD MORE ABOUT MAYBE
THE KARDASHIANS AND THERE IS,
THERE IS NO DISPUTE THAT THIS
SITUATION WAS SPAWNED BY THE
RELEASE OF THE VIDEO.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION ABOUT THAT. I THINK
THAT -- I THINK I SEE THE
PROBLEM. HERE'S YOUR PROBLEM,
YOU ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO GET
OUTRAGED ABOUT AN INTELLIGENCE
FAILURE THAT TRAGICALLY LED TO
SOME AMERICANS LOSING THEIR
LIVES.
ONE INTELLIGENCE FAILURE. AND
THEN, I MEAN,
IMAGINE THE OUTRAGE IF THERE WAS
A SECOND FAILURE RIGHT AFTER
THAT ONE THAT TRAGICALLY LED TO
EVEN MORE AMERICANS LOSING
THEIR LIVES? BUT, YOU ARE NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
YOU ARE JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS ONE INTELLIGENCE FAILURE
AND YOU ARE UPSET THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IN ITS HASTE TO
GET REELECTED PULLED SOME DODGY
FACE SAVING (bleep).
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE AFRAID
OF. WELL, I COMMEND YOU FOR
FINALLY GETTING IN TOUCH WITH
YOUR INNER OUTRAGE BECAUSE
IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY,
IN THE PREVIOUS DECADE
IT WAS AN EMOTION YOU DIDN'T
SEEM COMFORTABLE
ADDRESSING OR EXPRESSING. LIKE,
FOR INSTANCE WHEN FORMER BUSH
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
TOM RIDGE SAID HE WAS
PRESSURED BY ASHCROFT AND
RUMSFELD TO RAISE THE
NATION'S TERROR THREAT LEVEL
BEFORE THE 2004 ELECTION TO
HELP PRESIDENT BUSH'S ELECTION
CHANCES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, TOM RIDGE IS A GOOD AND
DECENT MAN ENTITLED TO HIS
IMPRESSIONS BUT THERE'RE JUST
THAT AND THERE ARE SOME FACTS
THAT STAND BETWEEN TOM RICH AND
THE SMOKING GUN.
>> IF FORMER HOMELAND
SECURITY CHIEF TOM RIDGE
WAS HOPING TO GENERATE BUZZ
ABOUT HIS UPCOMING
BOOK, MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
>> Jon: ZING.
THAT'S NOT OUTRAGE.
THAT IS SNARK.
SNARK IS NOT OUTRAGE, SILLY.
[LAUGHTER]